Y yo como chiquitico, en 1918, me sentó, y ya estaba todo mueble, como dado, y irse.
Entra de la mano, y quita el caballo, y voy con el caballo, y yo me quedo sentado.
Y pasó el gritor, gritar, cuando llegó papá, ¿a dónde se puede bocar?
Me quedaron allá, sentado, sin caballo, dejó el campo allá, y pensó que hubiera
miseria más grande.
¿Qué alemán fue el que quitó eso?
Un alemán de militares.
Pues ya eran rumores, ¿ustedes me entienden?
Que Alemania ya perdió la guerra.
¿Por qué hizo?
No puedo explicar.
¿A dónde fue?
Yo pensó, gritar, miren cuando llega mi papá, ya de nada.
Vale.
Mi papá, discutiendo con mi mamá, que descansa, yo como chiquito, niño de seis años, huyó
para el mismo pueblo, empezó a buscar papá, y yo me quedé con mamá.
Otra vez construyó una casita, empezó trabajando, ahí en el campo, para comer.
¿Dónde estaban ahorita?
En Vítichna, Vítichna.
Y papá llamó a mi mamá, no llamó por teléfono, no era teléfono, no era autobuses, no era
aviones, era 26 kilómetros de ciudad.
Como está en papel, escriben de Israel, ya todo.
Y yo ya estudiaba, mire, hebreo.
Era un muchacho, ya tenía poquito cultura, pobre.
Mi mamá no comía, y dio comida a él, que estudiaba conmigo, Talmud.
¿A quién?
El muchachito mayor, muchacho mayor.
Por ejemplo, que ella tenía poquito comida, ella no comía, guardó para él que él come,
que estudiaba conmigo, y era más joven.
¿Cómo se llama el muchacho?
Schneiderman.
Está conocido aquí en Caracas, Leon Schneiderman.
¿Qué ustedes quieren saber?
No quise nombrar, no tengo nombrado.
Pues no me gusta, pues aquí se puso muy grande, ¿ustedes me entienden?
Este va a mirar la historia como era.
El mundo nunca nos sigue como uno quiere, no como el tiempo está demostrando.
Este Leon Schneiderman dijo a mi mamá,
Hanna, que tú pudiste dar su hijo, Itzik Meyer, que es tuyo,
no sé qué puede ser de él.
Yo tenía una sola vez, y así, mire, ¿qué significa eso?
Bueno, ¿ustedes saben?
La vida no es como uno quiere, no como está demostrando.
Al fin, yo y mi mamá nos fuimos para ese pueblo mítico.
En 1918, Estados Unidos obligó, todo el mundo sabe de ustedes,
no sé si ustedes saben esa historia,
obligó a Alemania que quiere salir de Polonia.
Quiere salir de Polonia.
Cuando salieron de Polonia, entonces Rusia quiso dominar Polonia.
Rusia no era preparada para ganar una guerra.
Rusia era mucho hambre.
Cada uno de ustedes seguro sabe la revolución de 1918 que era Rusia.
Millones de gente murieron de hambre.
Entonces, guerra entre polacos y rusos.
Allá, ese muchacho es mi hermano, ya tenía 20 años.
¿Cuál?
Pincas, como usted está en la foto.
Quisieron él llevar con caballos que ayudan, militares,
o dar agua, dar comida para ayudar.
No era militar, no se vino a trabajar con fusil.
Y polacos ya antes, cuando eran alemanes, ya se prepararon con armas.
Entonces mi papá me dijo que descansa, Samuel Reis.
Es hijo mío de 20 años.
Yo pasó la guerra en 1905, la guerra japonesa.
Yo era capitán.
Dejan mi hijo y yo voy con usted a ayudar.
Yo sé más ayudar que él.
Aceptaron.
Dejaron el hijo.
En 1905, tenía nueve días en la frontera, sin agua, sin comida y sin nada.
El regreso era exacto, antes de Semana Santa, lo cual es como ahorita.
Mi mamá que descansa, mire, yo no sé cómo logró.
Tomó carne ternera, hizo para Semana Santa.
Tú sabes que no se come hummus, tú sabes, ¿no?
Hizo con papas.
Y esto hizo daño a él, la comida.
Enfermó.
Tú sabes que medicina no era.
Médicos eran muy pocos.
El único semi-médico se llamaba Bengler.
Mi hermano mayor, poco un capucino.
Si pagó o no pagó, esto yo no puedo decir.
Y dejaron ver.
Yo mismo se quemó.
Yo también enfermó.
Tifus, ¿sabe qué tifus, no?
Bengler vino.
Él conocí muy bien mi mamá.
Me dijo, Bengler, yo no te puedo pagar.
Yo quería que me salvas, mi esposo y mi hijo más chiquito.
Él estaba en una camita así, y una camita así, aquí por el paso, mire.
Y demás hermanos dormían en un piso.
Entonces Bengler dijo así, que yo para tu hijo no era el medio.
Quiere morir.
No para su esposo, yo doy remedio.
Mi hermano regresó con el médico para la dada.
Acompañó a segundo hermano, Erzo, para la dada.
Y trajeron un remedio.
Cuando tomó el remedio, llamó a los cuatro hijos.
Mis hijos, yo estoy muriendo.
Papá, ¿qué pasó?
Yo estoy muriendo.
Entonces mi hermana mayor, que está aquí fuera de allá,
dijo, papá, ¿a dónde estás dejando a nosotros?
Dice mis hijos, yo no me acuerdo qué dijo esa, no discúlpeme, me dijo mi mamá, que me explicó.
Yo estoy dejando un mundo lindo y bello.
Depende de cómo usted va a caminar en este mundo.
Como era, muestro yo a Saint-Albert, por la ley.
Los muertos se ponen la cara blanca.
Se volteó, con la cara a la pared, y murió.
¿Sabe qué?
¿Qué es religión?
Cuando uno siente que ya quiere morir,
quiere volcarse con la cara para la pared, porque la pared siempre es blanca.
Aquí no es todo blanco, aquí hay papel que están forando, que están pintando,
no hay amigas, no hay de hacer cosas.